humans have been using roller conveyors
for thousands of years the ancient
Egyptians used wood rollers to move the
large stones needed to build the
pyramids
today's conveyors are more complex but
the basic concept is still the same many
factories use roller conveyors to
transfer materials from one station to
another during assembly they can move
heavy loads up to 65 feet in a minute to
make the conveyor rollers this Factory
starts with hollow steel tubes they
deliver to the factory in batches after
they arrive a bandsaw cuts the tubes to
length the diameter can vary from batch
to batch so an employee obtains the
exact measurements he inputs the
measurements into a computer that
controls this laser the laser etches the
company logo onto a sheet of thick steel
and cuts out support disks for the
roller axles
the support disks fit perfectly into the
hollow rollers an employee feeds a flat
sheet of Steel to a computerized brake
press it bends the sheet into a vertical
rail for the conveyor frame here's the
steel before and after bending a worker
joins two vertical rails with steel
supports called cross members he welds
them where they meet this creates the
frame for the roller conveyor then they
paint the frame the paint isn't just for
decoration it also protects against rust
next they install the chain driven axle
that will spend the roller an employee
measures it and confirms its dimensions
another worker slides three support
disks onto the axle
you
he welds the disks in place the disk on
the end fits snugly to the roller rims
this is why pre-measuring is so
important he welds the disks to the ends
of the tubes
he slides roller chain sprockets onto
the end of the axle and welds them in
place he uses a dial indicator to
measure the circumference of the roller
and confirm that it's sufficiently round
using a forklift the team lifts the
motor and places it in the conveyor
frame they slide the motors threaded
rods into holes drilled in the frame
an employee places metal washers on the
threaded rods then he screws nuts to
them securing the motor to the frame he
installs a bearing on the end of the
roller axle next workers arrange the
rollers on the conveyor frame they place
the bearings on the flange of one of the
vertical rails they attach the bearings
to the rail with socket screws one of
the workers attaches the welded steel
chain to the teeth of the sprocket
wheels he joins the sections of the
roller chain with links then he drops
the ends of the chains down to the motor
the worker loops the chains around the
motor sprockets and connects the ends
with the jointer plate and retaining
clip now they're ready to put this
roller conveyor to the test
an employee measures the rotational
speed of the rollers with an instrument
called a tachometer
he also tests the conveyors ability to
move heavy objects once approved the
roller conveyor will be shipped to
another Factory where it will be an
important part of the manufacturing
process